hey guys how's it going so I wanted to
do a little July 4th Independence Day
celebration video and I thought I might
do a makeup video it's been a while I
think the last one I did was Kim
Kardashian I'm losing my voice because I
was pulling called 'union
and yelling like maniac I am gonna do a
really great look that you can wear to a
picnic you can wear it to a BBQ really
you know I don't want to limit you guys
use your imagination
ok come to pull my hair up and we're
gonna start this look it's gonna be so
fashionable f it's my passion
there are no words we're gonna start off
with I don't know what we're gonna do
okay
let's prime the eye actually if we're
only gonna do one because I want this
eye this look is gonna be called a
firework cuz baby you're fine well I
think the fireworks I think of SHINee
I'm gonna get so many numbers this
barbeque looks like I got punched this
firework is ready to Sparkle finally the
cops are gonna be quiet get a whole lot
a whole lot of silver and this really
just lets you shine bright like a
diamond
well some may think that this is going a
little bit overboard but I say yeah oh
no 24 hour tattoo Oh God but for the
next I I want it to scream work up so
good but you know what else we need no
flight is complete without some stripes
shine bright like a diamond we're ready
for some stripes merica this is a big
stripe because I'm loud and proud and I
want everyone to know about Baroque art
I'm gonna turn this eyebrow
jillee into a strike this is actually
lipliner so we're gonna need some blue
in this somehow so I'm gonna maybe why
freaking not it's Independence Day I'm
free home of the brave
I'm brave what's it saying it's saying
mr.akash said oh look at this a ruby
eyelashes or red what else do I have
oh I feel like eating a little something
in here looks like a zit
I mean this is gonna be good I mean if
you guys have a date or something
honestly I think this is probably gonna
be the one you're gonna want to do
because you want your man to know that
you're not afraid that you're not afraid
of yourself I wouldn't be afraid of a
sign they're bright like a diamond
I don't really know what else I can do
except put my hair down you really get
wild what do you guys think
ah happy fourth of July maybe wash my
face now